SSpeaker 1: o Rudy Giuliani is not
having a particularly good week. First,
he claimed that he was almost killed at a grocery
store. Then the surveillance video came out and
someone patted him on the back. He claimed that he
was hit so hard that the person standing next to
him almost fell down. And then the video came out
and all of it was untrue. So that was not a great
start to the week for Rudy Giuliani. Then Cassidy
Hutchinson testified that Rudy Giuliani wanted a
pardon from Donald Trump around the time of the
January 6th riots. And Rudy Giuliani accidentally
admitted to that request. And I'm going to
show you the message. He subsequently deleted
the tweet. So let's go piece by piece. First and
foremost, here is Cassidy Hutchinson on Tuesday
saying Rudy Giuliani and Mark Meadows, they
both wanted pardons related to January 6th.
Speaker 4: Rudy Giuliani ever suggest that he
was interested in receiving a presidential pardon
related to January 6th? He did. Ms.. Hutchison,
did White House Chief of Staff Mark Meadows ever
indicate that he was interested in receiving
a presidential pardon related to January 6th?
Mr. Moto said to seek that pardon.
Speaker 1: So very, very clear. Rudy
wanted a pardon and Mark Meadows wanted a pardon.
Okay, fine. So Tuesday night, Rudy Giuliani tweets
once again, the January 6th committee of Russian
collusion liars suborned perjury from Cassidy
Hutchinson. I specifically told President
Trump I did not want or need a pardon. I
also have witnesses to corroborate that she and
the committee are perpetrating yet another lie.
Okay. And then on Wednesday, Rudy doubled down.
But he unfortunately admits to the entire thing.
Rudy tweets, The January 6th witch hunt cabal
has now exceeded even its prior fraudulent.
The strange grammar. Okay. The last witness was
a reckless liar, contrary to her false testimony.
She was never present when I asked for a pardon.
Did she says that you slapped your wife, sir? She
was not there when I slapped my wife. I mean, sir,
I mean, I didn't slap my wife. Then Rudy says,
Actually, I told the president I did not want or
need one. He then subsequently deleted that tweet.
Not going particularly well for Rudy Giuliani.
Now, one explanation would be he's just confused
what he meant by she wasn't there when I asked
for a pardon. Is he never asked for a pardon?
Maybe that's actually what he meant. But it
doesn't look particularly good when you say she
wasn't there when I did the things she accuses
me of doing. And then you delete the tweet.
All very, very strange. And again, put the
people under oath. Get Rudy there and have
them testify under oath, get everybody there
and have them contradict her claims under oath.
I don't for a second. Listen, when you're
asked about things from a year and a half ago,
you are stressed now when you're being asked
the questions. It was a stressful time then.
I am completely sympathetic to the notion
that there will be details that could be off
in this testimony. I think that applies to the
friendly witnesses. I think that applies to the
hostile witnesses. I think that that's perfectly
plausible. But right now, we have the under oath
testimony of a very composed Cassidy Hutchinson,
and then we have the confusing and contradictory
and sometimes bizarre admissions and subsequent
deletions reacting to her claims. Put these
people under oath and we will evaluate their
claims with all of the same consideration
and seriousness that we're evaluating the
claims made by Cassidy Hutchinson, period.